I've been playing Lori Strode  for 44 years  and that last day was not a particularly  harrowing day it was a pretty simple  shoot day  but everybody knew was my last day and  the entire crew was there  and all the actors showed up  and it was  really emotional  it was powerful because  I am  I am her  and I've been her for a long time  and that  that relationship is the most important  professional relationship I will ever  have  and so ending a professional  relationship that's the most important  one of your life  is is powerful  and very bittersweet  and I will  I'm not going to cry here I won't do it  but I have I have shed many a tear  because the people  who love her  love me  because I am her  and I feel it from people I feel it I  feel the for whatever reason people have  have leaned in and and really taken her  into their lives as their sister  and I feel like I have a really giant  family now  and it's hard to say goodbye to them